في مقابله خاصه بالجزيره اكد الرئيس
الكولومبي السابق اذا دوكي ان دوله قطر
اظهرت تطورها الاقتصادي والسياحي كما اشد
بحسن الاستقبال الذي كان مجالا رحبا
للتعرف على الثقافه والعادات القطريه
الصدق في اوجه عديده وراينا انتقادات
كثيره تشكك اولا فيما اذا كانت قطر قادره
على تنظيم مونديال وكيف يمكن تنظيم بطوله
مونديال في مكان بعيد للغايه وكيف يمكن
تنظيم مونديال بكل تلك التعقيدات اللوجسيه
ولكن في الحقيقه تم اثبات انه اولا هناك
تميز لوجيسي ورايناه هناك خطوط اتصال مع
كل العالم ورايين ملاعب ربما تكون احدث
تكنولوجيا الاحتضان احداث ضخمه ورايين بثا
عظيما عبر التلفزيون ومختلف في شبكات
التواصل وراينا كيف جاء مشجعون من كل
الدول التي شاركت في هذه البطوله بل ورئين
ايضا كيف شعر الناس بانهم جيدا وتم
استقبالهم بمحبه وعاطفه طيبه من جانب
المواطنين القطريين وراينا ايضا كيف ان
قطر بعيدا عن الرياضه وضعت في فضاءات
المرئيه للجميع فعاليات ثقافيه فريده من
نوعها وبصرف النظر عن ذلك تمكنت قطر ايضا
من اظهار تصورها الاقتصادي وتطورها
السياحي لان قطر بدون شك دوله حققت تحولا
في مجال الطاقه ولكنها ايضا حققت تحول
اقتصاديا وكل ما يجري تقديمه اليوم للعالم
سيجلب بمرور الوقت المزيد من الزوار مع
الاخذ في الاعتبار ان لديها اكثر من 5
ملايين زائر غير مقيم في السنه